here's a question for you joey because
you you could probably judge us the best
but
ever since the beginning of time there's
always been this debate of subs versus
dubs you know
the japanese japanese voice acting is
always great
has there been any show or any anime
from your experience that it's just
bad voice acting from like a japanese
side of things
man that's hard to say because at least
with voice from my understanding in my
experience
at least japanese voice acting in anime
yeah has just
had an insanely high bar to jump over oh
now
even ever since even you know like i
could obviously go back to you know an
anime from the 70s
yeah yeah and probably find some bad
voice acting there but that's because it
was
a medium that was still getting refined
since the 60s right yeah
but i think honestly every anime i've
seen
since you know the late 80s early 90s
i don't think there's been a maybe
there's been like one or two bad voices
or one or two maybe like
under qualified voices compared to
everybody else in that same show but
i wouldn't say there's an entire show
that has like bad voice acting being the
same way that there are bad dubs
yeah exactly but and i don't know maybe
that's like a cultural thing maybe
i think it's because they've set up a
system here that ensures they're getting
voice talent right yeah
yeah they have schools specifically for
voice action yeah yeah we don't really
have that in the world
it's you go to acting school and maybe
you stumble into voice over right if
that's what you like
there's not really a system but their
entire you know like four year
universities no right exactly
say yes it's the same reason why like
korea are normally amazing at esports
they have the infrastructure there to
support
like making this talent yeah and you
know in japan obviously you
they've been having those schools for a
while where the bar is getting pushed
constantly and constantly
yeah whereas it's not really like that
in the west exactly
and and you know the the great thing as
well with the structure of at least the
japanese voice acting in anime is that
if there is a new voice actor or actress
that comes into the industry
they usually start them off with very
very small roles maybe like one line or
even just background noise to kind of
get them used to that environment
and give them as much experience as
possible and then maybe after they do
you know
10 rolls of playing you know person
passing behind
the main character after the tenth time
then they can give them
overall awareness it's very japanese
right yeah there's two more lines
okay the next one will give you five
lines yeah we'll give you ten lines and
then it just builds and builds from
there unless
if it's someone that just has insane
amount of talent from the get-go yeah
they're just confident enough to put
them into a show and then they make a
name for themselves because
some of the best dub performances have
been from actors where like they weren't
acting in any other animated shows oh no
yeah
i i think i think um i think johnny and
bosch
like stumbled into his first dub role by
accident
um i think same with steve bloom as well
uh yeah i think so
from what i found out it's been a while
since i heard the stories
like both fantastic voices yeah god
i think oh was the guy who did light in
the death note dub he did a lot of the
ocean dubs in canada he did like yeah
because he did rock from black lagoon as
well
i think he was doing my little pony
before really
after anything
i know the guy voices lad rousseau in
baccano i hadn't done any animation no
no
i remember a lot of like back then a lot
of the voice actors who voiced in
baccano was like that was like their
first role yeah
there's a lot of unknown voice actors
and actresses in that in in that show
great show yeah questions questions to
you guys then we've so with the
ridiculously high bar
that japanese voice acting has what are
what are some
shows that eat you know that even stand
out for you with like the
japanese voice talent and voice acting
i'll tell you the show that stands out
to me most recently yeah and that's b
stars
oh yeah b stars has absolutely like
insane voice acting
and it's very different because it
doesn't it doesn't it didn't sound like
your typical
anime kind of voice acting it sounded
very grounded and i don't know who the
voice actor for lego series but his
his acting was so good like lego she and
luis
yeah was like they both had like the
voice acting performances of that year
oh any anime easily easily in in my in
my opinion like eve
even with shows like attack on titan
three coming out that had some great
voice acting i still think
b stars was like just a cut above the
rest i think it's just because b stars
as a show was just a cut above the rest
yeah yeah yeah like it was just such a
[ __ ] amazing show i'm trying to think
of any japanese shows that really blew
me away with voice act jojo
i mean my mandio kills it
like that perform i spoke about this
before like his performance like
his dear like meme's aside like it's
[ __ ] amazing oh yeah
he's [ __ ] crazy and everyone in part
five i would argue as well has
fantastic voices i think i think the
thing with japanese voices was that
they can just do casting so well yeah
they get it yeah
they understand how important casting is
for a character